this morning our series protecting the
planet looks at an unexpected side
effect of that massive expansion in
renewable energy driven mainly by wind
and solar power green energy surpassed
coal for U.S electricity generation for
the first time ever as of last year but
there's also a growing problem for this
young industry what to do with all the
solar solar panels and wind turbine
blades after they wear out
senior National and environmental
correspondent Ben Tracy has this story
this panel is not necessarily suitable
for reuse at the solar panel recycling
plant in Yuma Arizona hey I like talking
trash
Dwight Clark oversees the machines that
can process more than 7 000 used solar
panels a day
solar is the fastest growing source of
energy in the U.S the panels last for 25
to 30 years but more than 90 percent of
used solar panels end up in landfills by
2030 the amount due to be retired would
cover about 3 000 football fields there
was no planning to handle the waste Adam
segai is CEO of the simply named we
recycle solar in Yuma we said what can
we come up with that just gets right to
the point you found it
he says a tsunami of solar waste is
coming and his company hopes to ride the
wave by recycling or reusing nearly 70
million pounds of panels each year they
are mostly made of glass and aluminum
valuable and reusable materials as solar
panels improve many are being ripped out
long before they age out how old are
these about three to four years old
there's absolutely a market for someone
to take three to four Euro panels I
would take three to four year old panels
put them on my house exactly 90
efficiency the problem is the trash not
the technology scientists say renewable
energy mainly solar and wind power is
key to combating climate change allowing
us to ditch fossil fuels and their
Planet warming carbon emissions
but the answer blowing in the wind
raises an uncomfortable question what is
all this stuff this is our storage of
windmill blades before we process them
this Quarry outside of Louisiana
Missouri is filled with decommissioned
wind turbines and nearly 200 foot long
blades chopped into several pieces they
are built not to break the balsa wood
there's fiberglass there's the resin but
it's Julie Angelo's job to break them
she's with violia a company that figured
out how to cut these blades down to size
so they can be recycled so if you
weren't recycling all of this what would
happen what would what also does happen
unfortunately
um a lot of those end up in landfill
these windmill blades are being buried
in the ground in Casper Wyoming by 2050
the world's wind industry is estimated
to produce more than 47 million tons of
Blade waste each year a black eye for
green energy
spent months finding the right mix of
industrial shredders to tear them apart
so from a massive windmill turbine blade
to this to this yes they sell the blade
remains to cement companies which use it
to fuel their Kilns instead of coal they
say that cuts their Planet warming
carbon emissions by nearly 30 percent
overall the renewable recycling industry
is small and it's still cheaper to send
the waste to landfills but in Europe
used blades are being remade into
everything from playgrounds to bike
shelters to Bridges
so far violia has processed nearly 3 000
blades you took something that's
supposed to be indestructible and you've
destroyed it yes congratulations
a renewable Revolution should provide an
endless supply of business for CBS
mornings I'm Ben Tracy in Louisiana
Missouri
I remember when solar panels hit the
scene but I had no idea or even thought
about what happens when they age out I
just thought they're going to be up
there forever and I thought too not so
folks yeah now we got a solution